did you start doing this while on
probation because of the money or
because it gave you
meaning God you know I mean part a big
part of that the reason is I I did not
want to move back in with my parents and
I didn't want my father to see me
struggling and I didn't want him
to it
was my success
he had no idea My Success had been the
first time he'd ever really been proud
of me does that financial success yes at
which point when was the first time you
told him you did something he was like
you could sense him being proud oh when
I became a mortgage broke when I when I
became a mortgage broker and I went to
work for the company and what we're
talking about within a week I got a
client three days later I got a client a
week later got a client two days later
got a client like I closed four loans my
first month and my dad was like well
well how much money are you going to
make and I'm like I'm charging this much
this I got a point on the back I got
this I boom I'm thinking I'm going to
walk home after taxes like 10
11,000 Jesus God Almighty you know are
you Ser well well we'll see don't start
counting your chickens before that you
know and and then you know two whatever
three weeks later four weeks later you
know boom I got a check it's like $9,000
or something or and then you know the
next month it's 12 and the next month
it's 16 and you know then they make me a
manager and you know um it's just he
didn't know and you was illegitimate no
he thinks he thinks my son he's
brilliant you know he's great he's
wonderful I I had you know was certainly
not proud of me prior to that um but you
know my dad was athletic he was
extremely bright I mean
brilliant and I was a kid who had had to
be put into special schools who barely
graduated high
school who ended up going to college and
getting a degree in Fine Arts because I
was never going to be able to get a
degree in Business it wasn't going to
happen so when I graduated college I
remember with the the degree in Fine
Arts he said the best you'll the best
thing you can do with that is maybe you
could draw caricatures at Disney World
you know what I'm saying which wasn't a
compliment by it wasn't like hey you
could draw
um so yeah he you know and then I turned
around and I I tried to go to work for
State Farm insurance which is who he
worked for he worked for them for like
40 something years and I failed the
aptitude test so then I went and worked
for another insurance company and I was
a an insurance adjuster but I couldn't
keep up with the workload then I end up
working construction I'm still barely
paying my bills you know that's
basically where my dad felt like that's
that's you know he was polite to me you
know we was we were were you know
cordial but yeah I wasn't I I think he
felt he deserved a better kid so well
when you when you started doing
mortgages that's when he was like of
course he was like this kid's got
something I'm driving I'm driving a new
I got to just pulled in in a new car and
I got a I just bought a house that was
you know four or five blocks away from
his house from where I grew up for where
he lives you know lived at that time you
know six blocks away way from where my
sister's married to her lawyer husband
like I'm doing pretty good and then
within three months we bought you know
we're my new wife we buy a um a quadplex
and then we're buying a Triplex and
another quadplex and a 10 unit and a
duplex and another duplex and a quad and
it's like what the hell is going on this
guy is blowing up he's going on vacation
here and vacation here and you know so
he you know and so when when when the
FBI comes in and they indict me and I I
take the three years probation like I
mean the probably the worst thing in the
world you know other than going to
prison would have been just having to
just sell everything and go move in and
start over and sell used cars not that
there's anything wrong with selling used
cars but I just felt like you know I
just didn't want to disappoint him any
more than I already had so I thought I'm
going to flip houses and then I'll start
maybe a development company so I'll buy
some vacant lots and all this and that
the problem is
these houses I'm buy them for 50,000 if
I fix them up and sell them maybe I make
20 25,000 and then you got to find a a a
qualified borrower it's very hard to
find a qualified
borrower that wants to live in ebore
City back then it's I still think it's
rough but those same houses are going
for three and 400,000 so you know I'm
buying houses I got I got to get
qualified borrowers I have do all the
renovations it's it's a nightmare you
know and if I you know looking back it's
like okay well then you got to bite the
bullet it's just what you have to do I
didn't want to do that I didn't want to
do it whether it was laziness or I don't
know you know I just thought I'm good at
this I'm going to run I'm just going to
start running a scam I'm going to figure
out how to drive the prices up buy the
houses for 50 record them at 200,000 and
then have these synthetic identities buy
all the properties refinance them pull
out the cash make six months worth of
payments let them all go into
foreclosure and that really really
started working
well